good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 2501 object
class safe special containment
procedures SCP 2501 is to be kept in
storage vault 3h at research site 45
only personnel with special exemption
key cards will be allowed to access SCP
2501 however the use sand or misuse of
SCP 2501 is strictly prohibited
punishable up to termination all
previous documentation regarding SCP
2501
is to be kept on high-security
foundation servers because of the
destructive potential of SCP 2501
special exemption key cards will only be
granted under special authorization from
the o-5 council description SCP 2501 is
a mechanical gauntlet designed to be
adapted to a human hand and forearm SCP
2501 is made of an unknown lightweight
material and is powered through unknown
means SCP 2501 shows no markings or
numbers to give any indication of an
origin or manufacturer the CP 2501
appears to be in need of maintenance
although knowledge of repairing certain
defective mechanisms is currently beyond
foundation researchers a key operated
safety switch is installed on the
underside of SCP 2501 although it
appears to be defective due to the key
being dislocated inside the lock
cylinder thereby keeping it affixed in
the position labeled with the word on in
russian there is also a slightly
corroded rotary control knob located on
the left side of the wrist this knob is
located to the furthest clockwise
position and will
turn counterclockwise the setting labels
are too worn to be decipherable but are
hypothesized to be numbers in increasing
range SCP 2500 ones anomalous properties
manifest when a user inserts his or her
arm into the socket and engages the
claw-like mechanism at the opposite end
when held in front of the users face SCP
2501 is able to exert an extreme amount
of pressure on an object within the
perspective of the user in relation to
the claw-like mechanism no upper limit
on the amount of pressure SCP 2501 can
exert has yet been observed SCP 2501
is not able to perform more dexterous
functions beyond rapidly opening and
closing distance from the user to an
object it does not affect the end result
neither does density or size of the
object the object during this process
always behaves as if two invisible
forces are exerting against it at
opposite ends to the point of structural
failure using SCP 2501 on media such as
fluids or gases has no effect the
following information requires a level
to access experimental test logs 2501 -
11 subject research technician using SCP
2501 on designated items procedure SCP
2501 used normally as it's designed
function results test one item steel
soup can full one meter distance result
destroyed via compression comments can
crushed it to a thickness of 0.08
millimetres soup had to be cleaned off
of lab equipment it was recommended that
future testing be conducted outside test
- item solid steel cylinder diameter 8
centimetres 20 meter distance result
flattened comets cylinder was compressed
into a disc measuring 1.6 metres in
diameter and
thickness of two millimeters test three
a 1962 Buick LeSabre decommissioned from
light vehicle pool distance 100 meters
result destroyed by compression comments
car crushed lengthwise to a thickness of
19 centimeters test for m3 Stuart light
tank decommissioned from mobile Task
Force Arsenal distance 200 meters result
destroyed via compression comments tank
crushed to a thickness of 84 centimeters
upon further analysis the steel Armour
has seemingly fused together due to the
extreme heat generated during the
process test 5 item concrete block 1
meter cubed distance 100 meters result
disintegrated comments block exploded
violently into fragments nothing was
found larger than 3 centimeters minor
injuries sustained by staff recommended
increasing minimum safe distances test 6
concrete block 1 meter cubed distance 4
kilometers result failed comments tests
conducted at night block was brightly
illuminated in order to aid in testing
user missed target and crushed light
fixture instead recommended using
binoculars and mount stability assist in
subsequent range tests test 7 item
high-altitude weather balloon distance
32 kilometers result destroyed via
compression comets tests conducted at
night large halogen light fixture with
sufficient battery life was affixed on
to the balloon test was successful
however debris was never found by
recovery teams extreme range
capabilities confirmed
test eight asteroid 1566 Icarus 2.9
times 10 to the power of 12 kilograms
distance perihelion 0.18 astronomical
units a family on 1.96 astronomical unit
result non-applicable comments cancelled
summary SCP 2500 ones anomalous
properties confirmed testing has been
suspended indefinitely under o5 command
SCP 2501 is to be placed back in storage
immediately
object class designated as safe for the
time being additional containment
protocols may need to be enacted as CP
2501 was remitted to a foundation
logistics center in an ornate shipping
case by an anonymous benefactor
benefactor is confirmed to have close
affiliations to Marshall Carter and dark
limited has supported by the item
description tag attached to SCP 2501 at
the time of delivery and a note
detailing the context of the parcel
archival document 2501 - oh 1 status
previously sold and in reserve currently
liquidate demand previously high-value
was apparently 500 thousand US dollars
or three hundred and three thousand
great British pounds availability
estimated worldwide one identifier was
exclusive item number 21 and in brackets
slightly worn condition description from
Marshall Carter and dark reads item is a
mechanical gauntlet made specifically to
crush objects simply using line of sight
a curious physics bender putting power
at your fingertips literally safety key
included with unit sold as is
level three access required archival
document 2500 102 to whom it may concern
I represent a professional community of
auctioneers collectors and dealers with
whom I am certain you are familiar I am
approaching your organization with an
item of mutual interest details are also
included inside the case rest assured
this is the right place for it
understandably you may have many
questions I am NOT able to divulge
details as it would stand as a conflict
of interest towards my colleagues and
clients still our motives for this
remittance is rather pertinent simply
put we are strictly dealers of art and
curios and very rarely there are items
that we come across that are not
inherently or obviously threatening to
that integral distinction such is the
nature of this item as valuable as it
may be we at Marshall Carter and dark
limited feel that it is in our mutual
benefit meaning us as well as the SCP
foundation that this remain in your
safekeeping
we usually retain a level of
impartiality for what our clients do or
do not do after the closing of a sale
however in light of a few isolated
incidents regarding our clients
intentions with this particular device
and their affiliations by and large it
is safe to assume that selling set item
would be a poor business decision on our
part storage also constitutes a problem
as an extreme demand for the item rather
interrupts the objectives and stable
business of Marshall Carter and dark
limited nobody enjoys being a teller at
a bank that is under threat of robbery
every waking moment in short keeping the
item in the inventory is more trouble
than it's worth
exceedingly so so for the sake of famous
landmarks monuments certain nations our
continued enterprise and quite possibly
the Sun or moon we hand this over to
persons more experienced and adept at
locking things away from the world
please accept our gift free of charge
from us to you
pS included is a box of la maison du
chocolat and a certificate of store
credit in the amount of great british
pounds has a further extension of our
gratitude forever grateful
lady Emily Alcott Carter June 8 1968
items included with the package outside
of SCP 2501 itself were recorded and or
destroyed no formal response from the
foundation has been sent regarding this
action okay I think that about does it
for today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
good bye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell dr. bright Darius Han Justin day
the Morrigan Durham
Maxon Joker Corvis and jayvo Jack Corey
Barker and escrow knock if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Vulcan thank you